I know where I came from I come from God
I didn't come from Monkey I came from
God through Adam through a long lineage
of man
did Jesus look like the son of God
no one thought so except a few people in
his days
David koresh was a spiritual leader who
saw himself as the final prophet in a
world that was coming to an end though
qarash and his followers were largely
peaceful they were amassing weapons as a
way to defend themselves when the
apocalypse came numbering about 100 the
Branch Davidians lived a quiet existence
in a compound known as Mount Carmel
located just outside of Waco Texas
then in 1993 the federal government
obtained a warrant to raid their
headquarters on the grounds that they
possessed illegal weapons so Texas we
have been watching as they have sent
vehicles in to Ram holes when they
showed up on February 28th of that year
federal agents with the Bureau of
Alcohol Tobacco firearms and explosives
thought they would be in and out
foreign
the main problem we had I don't believe
is that we were out maneuvered or out
planned the problem we had is that we
were outgunned but the Branch Davidians
resistant 50 ATF agents that come here
on would search and arrest warrants they
were greeted with lots of gunfire four
ATF agents and six Branch Davidians were
killed during the initial raid and after
a 51-day standoff The Siege ended with
the burning of Mount Carmel 76 Branch
Davidians including 25 children perished
after being trapped inside
Waco was the largest gunfight on
American soil since the Civil War and
many people point to it as a pivotal
moment in American history that created
new levels of distrust in the federal
government
they were amassing enough armaments to
outfit a small army
the ultimate goal was to arrest David
koresh and to seize all of the illegal
weapons almost every preconceived notion
I had about Waco Changed by the end of
it tiller Russell is the director of
Waco American apocalypse a new
docu-series on Netflix which brings to
light never before seen footage of the
government's Siege of Mount Carmel it's
easy to look at this story and sort of
say okay here's the You Know Jack booted
thugs of the government coming in and
taking away people's right or you can
you know read it contrarily from it from
a radically different perspective
but what I felt hadn't been done was
just taking all of these individuals who
lived through this incredible moment of
American history and treating them like
people and just
um allowing the audience to engage with
them as human beings and to draw their
own conclusions from it
buildings
what captivated me and hooked me was my
producers had Unearthed this amazing
archival footage which had been shot
inside the FBI's hostage negotiation
room and it really showed the day-to-day
kind of like mechanics of Hostage
negotiation which I don't think the
world has ever actually seen the FBI had
shot it initially thinking we're gonna
you know blow into town this will be
over in 24 hours we'll get everybody out
and then it became this you know epic
um you know epic story that ended up
stretching on for 51 days and so the
footage was shelved and nobody hit the
world had never seen it there's also all
of the recordings that the FBI made of
the individual calls they'd planted bugs
inside the compound there were
recordings of that you described the
series as like an exploration of what
leads people to the brink of the
apocalypse and what happens when they've
arrived could you kind of expand on that
what did you mean by that in this like
small town on the outskirts of Waco
Texas you have this vast and diverse
array of people who show up and they
feel that they're in the hands of a
Latter-Day Prophet somebody who is able
to take every single book in the Bible
and see this sort of Master vision for
the end of the world in a future new
world and he's so convincing and so
charismatic as a speaker that he's
enabled to kind of enrapture and capture
the imaginations and and attention of
all these people and it's a very diverse
group of folks right some of the folks
who are there literally grew up there
their entire lives had had been spent
there and some from had come from
Halfway Around The World from Australia
some had master's degrees some had come
from different religions and so you have
this like fantastically powerful orator
who's painting this vision of the end of
the world that vision is so strong that
it literally engulfs you know the press
it engulfs the FBI and it ends up being
manifested in the end and you know years
before there was a shootout before there
was a standoff you know David koresh had
been preaching the end of the world is
coming you know tanks are going to roll
up on our doorstep we're literally going
to be facing the apocalypse and we are
the chosen ones that'll you know lead on
to the new life and it was such a
powerful Vision that he conjured that it
that he literally manifested that in the
world you're talking about you know
Abram's tanks and and Bradley armored
personnel carrier arrayed around this
compound in a cow field in Texas it was
just a kind of truly astonishing
historical moment how did you kind of
wrestle with like there are so many
facts
facts 51 day siege that are still being
disputed like who shot first who started
the fire what happened to the door do
you think knowing the truth even now
still matters
I think that the truth always matters
but there's this
um
there's this poet Simon Ortiz who once
said there is no truth there is only
story and I think that there's something
really powerful about that in the sense
of everyone does conjure their own you
know version of what happens and no two
people's memories ever aligns exactly
there are these fundamental questions
okay who shot first and how did this you
know gunfight break out and you
interview people and immediately you
know they give you completely opposing
versions of it and and I think there is
this sort of symptom of the fog of War
right and then the same set of questions
exists you know at the end of the story
vis-a-vis okay here's this massive fire
and conflagration and loss of life and
all these
um you know people and children and it's
all happening in real time on national
television and
every person only holds a piece of the
story they only know what they saw what
they remember what their history tells
them and then it kind of gets cemented
in memory but at the same time I didn't
live it I wasn't there it's all based on
uh reconstructing it to the best of my
ability with the full cooperation and
participation of the people there David
Thibodeau is one of the nine Branch
Davidians who survived after escaping
the fire at Mount Carmel reason
interviewed Thibodaux back in 1999. at
the time of the interview he believed
that quresh had been unfairly demonized
by the media what role did the media
play in Waco and do you do you agree or
disagree that um koresh might have been
demonized somewhat by the media well the
media played an absolutely fascinating
role in Waco and and I think like at the
center of Waco is this massive failure
of communication it's the failure of the
FBI to communicate internally within
itself it's the failure fear of
um you know the FBI to understand what
the Branch Davidians want and what would
motivate them it's the inability of the
Branch Davidians themselves to
communicate with the outside world and
so the Press ends up being you know
caught between the you know the folks
inside the compound the FBI and the rest
of the world understanding the story
crash
showed himself pretty quickly they
immediately wanted media everybody wants
to find an angle and put a simple you
know lens and Define him as this and I
think my assessment is
that he was many things and and and I
think when you try to reduce it to just
one thing I think that he did in fact
probably feel himself to be a prophet I
think he also was having sex with
underage kids and I think he was a
powerful orator and speaker and I think
he also was you know somebody who was
lying and changing his mind and
manipulating everybody's just trying to
build their own portrait of who this guy
is and and how he brought us to the
doorstep of the Apocalypse
if your business is to go into a
building at four o'clock in the morning
and kill the bad guys and save the good
guys and risk your life of doing it
that's a different mindset than somebody
who's going to sit in a room and try to
talk a bad guy out
in the year since Waco we have
discovered many missteps taken by both
the negotiation team and the hostage
rescue team and kind of
miscommunications that were going on
between them can you describe the
Dynamics at play and why these two
groups you know had such a hard time
kind of working together to resolve the
situation we tend to think of the FBI as
this monolithic entity right which is
you know and and this is sort of great
institution but really at the end of the
day the FBI is composed of individuals
individual FBI agents and in this case
there was this very profound conflict
between the hostage rescue team which is
the door kickers the shooters the
snipers and then on the other hand you
know the negotiators the crisis
negotiation unit and their sort of jobs
are the same the job is you know in a
crisis where you have hostages to get
everybody out as safely as possible but
they're too radically radically
different approaches Waco it's hard for
us to remember but nothing like this had
ever happened before so everybody was
into this completely new scenario in
terms of scale intensity and duration
and of course there were failures and
mistakes that were made many of the
things that are roiling our culture
still today the the seeds of which were
kind of planted at Waco which is like
distrust to the federal government
conflicting viewpoints about you know
does God belong in in our society and
not the right to bear arms and and so
there are all these fundamental issues
which are you know God and guns and
children in America they've been with us
since the founding of this country
they'll be with us you know through the
end but Waco was a particularly volatile
and explosive example of when things go
horribly wrong you know what that Powder
Keg can be like the bombing of the
Murrah building in Oklahoma City two
years later by Timothy McVeigh is a
direct you know one-to-one
result of what happened in Waco there's
you know what happened the school
shooting in Columbine you know people
subsequently being inspired by McVeigh
and David koresh and the you know
arguable missteps of the government and
you know some people will draw a line
all the way to to January 6th and in
terms of you know the the distrust of of
government and sort of what you do when
institutions fail and what are the
rights and boundaries of citizens and so
I think the legacy of Waco is that we
are now in this in a sort of most
incredibly politically divisive moment
that certainly since the 1960s in
America and maybe not since the founding
of the country and by looking at these
stories where things went horribly wrong
my hope is a Storyteller and as a
filmmaker is we can revisit them and
understand them with a greater amount of
humanity so that those same mistakes
don't reoccur on the future
foreign